هي اول احتجاجات تشهد سقوط قتلى في العراق
منذ تشكيل حكومه جديده بقياده السوداني
نحو 300 شخص شاركوا في مظاهره في مدينه
الناصريه مركز محافظه ذي قار احتجاجا على
اعتقالات استهدفت نشطاء في الاونه الاخيره
ادت لصدامات اقيلا على اثرها قائد شرطه
محافظه 21
الصدامات وتاتي بعد اصدار محكمه في بغداد
حكما على نشط يدعى حيدر الزيدي بالسجن
ثلاث سنوات بعد ادانته بتهمه اهانه قوه
الحشد الشعبي على خلفيه تغريده تم حذفها
ونفذ زيد مسؤوليته عنها من جهتها اصدرت
محافظه ذي قار بيانا نددت فيه بوجود ما
اسماتهم بالمندسين بين المتظاهرين فيما
امر رئيس الوزراء العراقي بارسال لجنه
امنيه للتحقيق في الحادث ومدينه الناصريه
التي تشهد من حين لاخر تظاهرات متفرقه
كانت معقلا باريزا للاحتجاجات التي هزت
العراق عام 2019 حين شهيد موجه تظاهرات
طلب خلالها المحتجون بتغيير النظام لكن
الحركه تعرضت لقمع داما اسفر عن مقتل اكثر
من 600 شخص